[The Reward of Courage 1921, Original soundtrack by Maurice Saylor 2011, Composite version prepared by Colorlab for The National Library of Medicine  2012]
[The Reward of Courage --  An Eastern Film Corporation Production -- 220 West 42nd St. New York, N.Y.]  [Accompanying music begins]
[The Pleasantville Accessories Co.] [♪♪♪]
[A brick building is shown, with large windows, vent pipes on the roof, and telephone poles in front.] [♪♪♪]
[And Eugene Barnes, the efficient manager.] [♪♪♪]
[Mr. Barnes stands in a medical office, examining a notepad, with a bed shown behind him.] [♪♪♪]
[Car pulls up to doctor's office and Mr. Marshall Flint steps out.] [♪♪♪]
[The justly proud owner, Marshall Flint, and his daughter, Dorothy.] [♪♪♪]
[Marshall Flint and daughter, Dorothy, talking; she is at the wheel of the auto, and he stands beside her.] [♪♪♪]
[Mr. Barnes, still carrying the notepad, comes over and greets Marshall Flint.] [♪♪♪]
[Exit Marshall Flint.] [♪♪♪]
[Mr. Barnes talks to Dorothy and after a while Dorothy drives off.  Mr. Barnes walks into the building.] [♪♪♪]
[Marshall Flint enters his office.] [Music slows]
[Mr. Barnes walks into Flint's office, sits down, and speaks to him.] [♪♪♪]
["You remember that you let me start a clinic for first aid and regular examinations of the men a few months ago?'] [Music picks up]
["Yes, but I haven't seen any returns on that investment not even a report"] [♪♪♪]
["I'm coming to that. You recall that I said the service would pay for itself by preventing time lost on account  of sickness."] [♪♪♪]
[Barnes leans in and shows Marshall Flint a paper.] [♪♪♪]
["Well, I never gambled on a surer thing."] [♪♪♪]
[Close-up of a report titled Summary: 2000 Employees. Rows include Number of days lost through sickness, 1919-Before Clinic Was Installed and 1920-After Clinic Was Installed.] [♪♪♪]
[The two men continue talking over the report.] [♪♪♪]
[Mother Flint had more ambitious plans for her daughter than to be the wife of the plant Superintendent.] [♪♪♪]
[Mother Flint sits on the porch in a rocking chair, talking and rocking back and forth.] [♪♪♪]
[In the person of Mr. Morris Maxwell, apparently a gentleman of leisure, who had come to Pleasantville a year before.] [♪♪♪]
[Mr. Maxwell, a slick, mustachioed man, smokes a cigar in the chair next to Mother Flint, and talks to her.] [♪♪♪]
[Mother Flint points something out and Morris turns to look.] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy drives by in car.] [♪♪♪]
[The car parks and Dorothy emerges.] [♪♪♪]
[Mr. Maxwell stands to greet her while Dorothy says hello to mother] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy turns toward Maxwell but does not shake his offered hand, then enters the house.] [Single low note punctuates Dorothy's dismissing of Maxwell]  [♪♪♪]
[Barnes and Flint continue talking over statistics for the new clinic.]  [♪♪♪]
[Close-up of page of report titled Average number of days saved since clinic was installed per employee.]  [♪♪♪]
[Men continue talking.]  [♪♪♪]
["I never would have believed it. Let's go out and see how it's done."]  [♪♪♪]
[Mr. Flint and Barnes stand up and walk out of office.]  [♪♪♪]
[The Clinic of the Plant.]  [♪♪♪]
[A physician in a white coat with a stethoscope examines a seated patient while a nurse writes down the doctor's observations.]  [♪♪♪]
[Enter Flint and Barnes.]  [♪♪♪]
["If Mr. Flint could know how the men and their wives appreciate what this clinic has saved them in sickness and expense, he would take more interest in it."]  [♪♪♪]
[Barnes and Flint stand together talking, then walk away, into the medical office where the doctor speaks to them.]  [♪♪♪]
['I was skeptical and had to be shown Dr. Dale. I want to congratulate you all."]  [♪♪♪]
[Dr. Dale leads Marshall and Barnes into his office.]  [♪♪♪]
[Nurse gives Marshall a piece of paper.]  [♪♪♪]
["Regular physical examinations and hygienic instruction are the secrets. We discover the ailments before they become serious."]  [♪♪♪]
[The three men examine the paper.]  [♪♪♪]
["How do you suppose he caught it?"] [Dramatic music]
["He didn't catch it. Cancer is not contagious. Let me show you how it starts and develops."]  [♪♪♪]
[Dr. Dale opens book, begins  flipping through it ,and shows Flint and Barnes certain pages.]  [♪♪♪]
[Close-up of a page with a drawing of a man's face, titled Early Stage Lip Cancer.] [Continued dramatic music]
[Drawing of dermis with arrows pointing to Healthy Skin, Lymph Channels, and Veins.]  [♪♪♪]
[Same drawing, now showing dark layer atop the dermis and titled Irritated Skin.]  [♪♪♪]
[Drawing now shows dark layer extending deeper, and titled Pre-Cancerous Stage.]  [♪♪♪]
[Drawing now shows a dark growth expanding near the edge of the dark layer, titled Beginning Cancer.]  [♪♪♪]
[Drawing shows the dark growth spreading, titled Beginning Cancer, Easily Curable Stage.]  [♪♪♪]
[The cancer is shown spreading further, Dangerous But Curable, then Only Curable by Big Operation, then Cancer Cells Entering Lymph Channel.]  [♪♪♪]
[Image of the cancer spreading: Hopeless, Entering Veins.]  [♪♪♪]
[Drawing of man with lesion near lip; his torso is also shown:  After cancer cells enter the veins they are carried to all  parts of the body and produce new cancers.] [Music swells]
[Lesions appear all over man and grow larger.]  [♪♪♪]
[Back to Dr. Dale. Flint, and Barnes talking.]  [♪♪♪]
["And so, in Simpkin's case, where the growth is still restricted, he may yet be cured by immediate and expert treatment."] [Music fades slightly]]
[The three men continue talking; a woman wearing a hat enters the medical office and speaks to Dr. Dale.] [Music picks up]
["I have just come from the Simpkins home. The husband refuses to follow the advice of the hospital doctors and says he can cure the cancer with a paste."] [♪♪♪] paste."] [♪♪♪]"] [♪♪♪]
["I brought one of the empty paste jars with me."] [♪♪♪]
[The woman reaches into her purse and hands Dr. Dale the paste container.] [♪♪♪]
[The label reads: "Radiumized paste, No Knife, No Pain,  No Failure Recorded. Put up and Distributed by The Scientific Cancer Cure Institute, New York. N.Y."] [♪♪♪]
[Dr. Dale inspects the can and smells it.] [♪♪♪]
[Barnes records the name of the institute in a booklet.] [♪♪♪]
[The woman leaves and the men shake hands.] [♪♪♪]
[After dinner the chief subject of discussion was the Clinic.] [♪♪♪]
[Cut to Marshall Flint's home; Mr. Flint and the visitor Mr. Maxwell sit on either side of a table smoking a cigar with Mother Flint in the background.] [♪♪♪]
[Cut to daughter, with mother showing daughter how to sew something.] [♪♪♪]
[Back to Flint talking to Maxwell.] [♪♪♪]
["For instance, in the United States, about 90,000 people die each year of cancer. Many would have been saved had they come earlier for treatment. Dale says a lump in the breast is always suspicious."] [♪♪♪]
[Mr. Flint asks Mother Flint something.] [♪♪♪]
[Mother touches chest.] [♪♪♪]
[Maxwell continues to smoke, speaking to Mother Flint at the same time.] [♪♪♪]
["I am associated with a philanthropic group of scientists, including some of the best cancer specialists. Perhaps I can be of assistance if you can furnish me with the names of those suffering in this town."] [♪♪♪]
[Flint smokes and talks to Maxwell.] [♪♪♪]
[There are about twenty cases among the employees and their families. I'm sure Dr. Dale will be gald to furnish their names.] [♪♪♪]
[Part Two] [♪♪♪]
[At Mrs. Flint's request Miss Keene, the clinic nurse and an old friend of Dorothy's, called upon her the next day.] [♪♪♪]
[Miss Keene inspects Mrs. Flint's chest.] [Music takes on slower, darker tone]
["I'll ask Dr. Dale to suggest some reliable surgeon to examine it."] [♪♪♪]
[The two women sit facing each other, talking.] [♪♪♪]
["I only noticed it two weeks ago."] [♪♪♪]
[Women continue talking.] [♪♪♪]
[The examination had been made and Mrs. Flint's fears confirmed--] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy, looking worried, places her hand on Mrs. Flint's shoulder. Mrs. Flint is seated at a small table with a telephone.] [♪♪♪]
[Mrs. Flint picks up the telephone to place a call.] [♪♪♪]
[Marshall Flint answers the telephone in his office.] [♪♪♪]
[Mrs. Flint is shown speaking via phone to her husband.] [♪♪♪]
[Maxwell walks up the steps to the front door of the Flints' home and knocks; a household employee in a uniform opens the door.] [♪♪♪]
[Maxwell starts to enter the room where Mrs. Flint is talking on the telephone, but pauses, listening to her side of the conversation.] [♪♪♪]
["Dr. Clinton says an immediate operation is necessary. I told him we would call tomorrow and make arrangements."] [♪♪♪]
[As Mrs. Flint continues speaking, Dorothy walks away and looks out the window.] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy leaves the room.] [♪♪♪]
[Maxwell stands whistling behind the curtain, then goes in to talk to Mrs. Flint.] [Music takes on a sinister, staccato tone]
["I overheard the conversation with your husband. I beg to assure you that an operation for this condition is not necessary."] [♪♪♪]
[Maxwell continues speaking to Mrs. Flint, then urges her to sit down.] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy was deeply concerned about her mother's welfare.] [Slight swelling of music]
[Dorothy walks outdoors on a tree-lined path.] [♪♪♪]
[She was also uncertain what this might mean in her own life. Hadn't she heard that cancer was hereditary? Was she justified in thinking of marriage?] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy holds a flower in one hand; she appears sad and worried, on the verge of tears.] [Music becomes slower, somber]
[Maxwell and Mrs. Flint continue their conversation.] [Sinister, staccato notes are heard again]
["The institute with which I have the honor to be associated has thousands of cures to its credit without the use of the knife."] [♪♪♪]
[Maxwell pulls out a business card and hands it to Mrs. Flint.] [♪♪♪]
[Close-up of business card reading Mr. Morris Maxwell, The Scientific Cancer Cure Institute, New York, N.Y., Established in the Interest of Suffering Humanity.] [♪♪♪]
["As there are about twenty cases in this locality I think I could arrange to have them treated for about $200 a piece. You and Dorothy might interest Mr. Flint in the project to that extent."] [♪♪♪]
[Mrs. Flint examines Maxwell's business card as she and Maxwell continue speaking.] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy had decided to sacrifice her own happiness through the mistaken idea that the disease was hereditary.] [Music takes on a serious, contemplative air] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy and her husband-to-be are outside, walking past banks of flowers, talking over the situation.] [♪♪♪]
["But dearest, let's not be too hasty, first talk it over with someone who knows."] [♪♪♪]
[Her fiance holds Dorothy's shoulders, encouraging her. Dorothy looks down, then walks away.] [♪♪♪]
[A few days later.]
[Marshall Flint works at his desk with a secretary. Barnes works at his desk nearby.] [♪♪♪]
[Dr. Dale enters Marshall Flint's office.] [♪♪♪]
[Dr. Dale walks over rather quickly to Flint and hands him a letter.] [♪♪♪]
[Flint beckons Barnes to come over and examine the letter as well, and the men talk animatedly.] [♪♪♪]
[Close-up of letter dated Washington DC July 12, 1921, that appears to be addressed to Dr. Dale, Pleasantville Accessories Supply Co., Pleasantville PA. The letter reports that the Scientific Cancer Cure Institute is a fraudulent organization and is signed by someone named Douglas.] [Music turns ominous]
[After reading it, Flint stands up, slams the letter onto his desk, and starts yelling.] [Music takes on tone of urgency]
["He's expected to be at my home this morning. Let's hurry. Barnes pick up Brady and follow."] [♪♪♪]
[Flint grabs his hat and walks out accompanied by Dr. Dale. Barnes, picks up the phone and calls someone.] [♪♪♪]
[Maxwell and Mrs. Flint sits across from one another in her parlor, talking.] [Music lightens]
[Mrs. Flint takes out a checkbook, writes a check to Morris, and hands it to him.] [♪♪♪]
[Closeup of check for two hundred dollars.] [♪♪♪]
[Flint and Dr. Dale arive in a car at Flint's home.] [Urgent tone resumes]
[Flint and Dr. Dale come into the room with Morris and Mrs. Flint.] [♪♪♪]
[Flint takes check from Maxwell's hands.] [♪♪♪]
["I wasn't aware, my dear, that we owed Mr. Maxwell anything."] [♪♪♪]
[Mrs. Flint addresses a remark to Maxwell.] [♪♪♪]
["Surely $200 is little enough for the cure of cancer which will make it unnecessary for Mrs. Flint to undergo an operation."] [♪♪♪]
["As to that, Mrs. Flint and I prefer to be guided by the advice of our own physician."] [♪♪♪]
[Flint speaks and looks skeptically at Maxwell.] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy enters the room, wide-eyed and appearing concerned.] [♪♪♪]
[Dr. Dale takes out something from under a cloth and presents it to Maxwell.] [♪♪♪]
["Recognize it?"] [♪♪♪]
["I believe that it is put out by the Scientific Cancer Cure Institute."] [♪♪♪]
[Two men arrive in a car.] [Music picks up] [♪♪♪]
[Back inside the parlor, Dr. Dale takes out a piece of paper and hands it to Marshall.] [♪♪♪]
["The chemical analysis proves that it is absolutely worthless."] [♪♪♪]
["You can't prove it. It is a secret formula."] [♪♪♪]
[Barnes and Brady enter the room.] [♪♪♪]
[Maxwell tries to get out but Brady stops him.] [Insistent, dramatic notes are heard]
["But we can. The Post Office Department has been looking for you for some time for fraudulent advertising."] [♪♪♪]
[Brady escorts Maxwell out and Dr. Dale follows.] [Somber music]
[Barnes and Dorothy clutch one another and Mr. Flint leans down to speak to his wife.] [♪♪♪]
[And in the course of time.] [Music becomes lighter]
[Mr. and Mrs. Flint, Dorothy, Eugene, and a new baby are gathered in the garden. Mrs. Flint is reading a book while the rest are admiring the child.] [♪♪♪]
[Close-up of baby.] [♪♪♪]
[Flint leans over to Mrs. Flint and speaks to her.] [♪♪♪]
["Dearest, it is just six years since Dr. Clinton performed your operation- and how simple it was after all."] [♪♪♪]
["Yes, but I might have been misled and waited too long except for you. Dr. Clinton says it was only successful because it was taken in time."] [♪♪♪]
[Dorothy speaks.] [♪♪♪]
["I just love Dr. Clinton. He told me that cancer was not hereditary, and so I could marry Gene."] [♪♪♪]
[Family continues talking and smiling.] [♪♪♪]
[This film was prepared by the American Society for the Control of Cancer, a benevolent organization with headquarters at 370 Seventh Ave., New York. Further information may be secured upon request.] [♪♪♪]
[The Reward of Courage. Sound version prepared 2012 with a soundtrack composed by Maurice Saylor and performed by the Snark Ensemble. Composite version prepared by Colorlab.] [♪♪♪]
[The Snark Ensemble. Andrew Earle Simpson, piano - Maurice Saylor, bass clarinet, contra-alto clarinet, contrabass clarinet - Phil Carluzzo, percussion, glockenspiel, guitar, zither. Guest artists: Jeffry Newberger, violin - Julian Dale Barton, flute, English horn - Ben Redwine, clarinet. SnarkEnsemble.org] [Music ends abruptly]